et on évoque les grâces présidentielles
de donald trump avec allen or avocats
américains en direct de stanford aux
etats-unis c'est notre rubrique dette
extérieure à la nord
bonsoir merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte et france domaine d'ô
donald trump qui multiplie ces derniers
pouvoir avant de quitter la maison
blanche pourquoi ces personnes quel est
l'enjeu pour le président américain est
en jeu pour le pré ce temps une fait
simplement quelque chose qu'il a promis
de faire il a promis de traîner le
mariage mais en fait il ne fait que le
rendre plus profond en pardonnant à ses
amis et comment réagit l'opposition est
ce que c'est une provocation
je ne pense pas qu'il s'agisse d'une
provocation c'est un droit
présidentielle tant qu'ils disposent
ministration que ce problème au niveau
démocratique et il va maintenant jusqu'à
remettre en cause notre constitution en
utilisant un pouvoir qui n'était pas
censée être utilisée de cette manière
les démocrates est ce qu ils peuvent
engager des recours contre les décisions
de donald trump a pas de recours
possible au niveau constitutionnel
c'est un pouvoir présidentiel qui doit
être respecté c'est la première fois que
ce pouvoir être utilisé de cette façon
c'est la première fois qu'un président
utilise la grèce afin de protéger ses
proches de cette manière il y à un mois
donald trump grâce à michael flynn son
ex conseillers impliqués dans la
présumée affaire de collusion avec la
russie c'est grâce à ce qu'elle relance
des soupçons du côté de l'opposition la
fracture aux tests est si importante que
cela
relancer toute façon les personnes c'est
leur choix ont pris leur décision
le seul point positif c'est que les
personnes grâciées pourrait maintenant
porter témoignage et donner plus
d'informations sur ce qui s'est passé
exactement au cours de la présidence
trop mûrs mais en tout cas c'est
vraiment une honte cela va à l'encontre
de la constitution telle qu'elle a été
écrite mais en tout cas cela fait bien
partie des pouvoirs du président est-ce
que donald trump eux utiliser le droit
de grâce pour ce prêt se protéger
lui-même d'éventuelles poursuites on se
souvient en 2018 il avait assuré qu'il
avait le droit de gracier lui-même même
mais cette question épineuse un faut le
dire n'a jamais été tranché
véritablement par la justice américaine
l'avocat il est clair pour moi que l'on
ne peut pas se tenir à scier le fait qui
m'a dit qu'il peut le faire sans être un
expert ne vais pas dire qu'il le puisse
il pourrait essayer mais je pense que
cela ne pourrait pas être prise en
compte car la constitution n'est pas
conçu de cette manière cela ne m'est
jamais arrivé il pourrait cependant
démissionner et laisser son
vice-président le gracier né en matière
de juridiction cela n'aurait aucun sens
qu'ils puissent photographier est ce
qu'il ya des précédents dans l'histoire
des états unis lorsqu'elle est président
américain et quittent leur fonction est
ce que c'est quelque chose de
traditionnel qu'il graciait de la sorte
cela n'est pas du tout traditionnel
c'est en fait une
c'est vraiment scandaleux comme par
exemple sa grâce tu michael flynn
lorsqu'on gras si quelqu'un un
plissement on reconnaît qu'il ya eu un
crime cela ou ne signifie pas qu'on va
oublier le crime où l'on se rappellera
toujours que la personne a commis un
film et on s'en souviendra
cela signifie tout simplement que la
personne n'ira pas en prison
donc cela ne change pas la substance du
problème dernière question est ce qu une
grâce de julian assange est possible
avant que donald trump ne quitte la
maison blanche on le rappelle le
cofondateur de wikileaks le lanceur
d'alert menacé d'extradition vers les
etats-unis où il risque 175 ans de
prison pour avoir divulgué des documents
classés confidentiels il ya une dizaine
d'années également pour
pour espionnage notamment nous ne
pouvons que regarder ce qui se passe
il peut gracier pour des crimes fédéraux
mais pas pour des crimes au niveau des
états je suis certain qu'il y aura des
grâces bientôt supplémentaire et je
pense qu'il y en aura beaucoup qui vont
intervenir avant ou la grâce et des
personnes qui ont menti devant la cour
où la gracier des assassins il aa grassi
des garde-côtes qui ont tiré sur des
personnes qui souhaitait franchir la
frontière en prétendant que c'était des
trafiquants de drogue
ce sont donc des coupes de personnes peu
recommandables mais il a également
gracié des personnes qui ont passé trop
longtemps en prison environ 5
je pense merci à la naure d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat américain en direct de
stanford aux états unis